JOANNA SMITH: Hello everybody,
and welcome back to Google+
Developers Live.
I'm Joanna Smith, and I'm a
developer programs engineer
for Google+.
And today I have our fantastic
intern Sam Stern, who wrote
the documentation we published
this morning at
developers.googl
e.com/+/web/facebook.
And what we wrote here is an
article on how to add Google+
to an existing Facebook
integration.
So Sam, why don't you tell
us about your project.
SAM STERN: Thanks, Joanna.
So the idea of my project is
that we have a lot of great
resources on our developers site
for how to get started
with Google+ if it's your
first identity provider.
But where there was a gap was
what if Google+ is not your
first identity provider, and
specifically, what if you
already have Facebook integrated
into your website?
How can you get started with
Google+, and overcome the
unique challenges that you run
into when Google+ is your
second or third identity
provider?
JOANNA SMITH: So how did you,
as an intern, gain this
perspective and come to
understand this point of view?
SAM STERN: So the easiest way
to pretend to be a Facebook
developer with Facebook
integrated into their app is
to build an app with Facebook
integration.
Which is what I spent my first
few weeks here doing.
And from there, I went to add
Google+ on top, making note of
what was easy, what was hard,
or just what was different
that might be interesting to a
developer going through the
same experience.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
So I guess the next logical
question is,
what did you learn?
What was different?
What was easy?
What was hard?
SAM STERN: There are three main
things you have to do.
The first thing is you
have to get started.
You have to add the Google+
JavaScript to your web page.
You've got to get the sign
in button on your page.
And some basic things that are
a little bit different from
the perspective of a
Facebook developer.
From there, there are a couple
pain points that you're going
to want to tackle, such as
authentication on the server
side, and on the client side.
And after that, it goes into
translating features.
If you're sharing on Facebook,
how do you share on Google+?
And beyond that, what can you
do that's unique to Google+,
and how can you really make the
user experience better by
adding Google?
JOANNA SMITH: So it sounds
like there's a
lot of content there.
But let's break it down,
and let's talk about
authentication.
What did you learn about
managing multiple identity
providers across multiple
platforms?
SAM STERN: So the first thing
I did with authentication--
I tried to jump right in,
and the code got messy.
And what I learned quickly
is you have to
separate your concerns.
You want to keep your Google+
code in one place, your
Facebook code in
another place.
And the code that holds it all
together is what you should
really focus on.
That's where you should manage
your authorization.
So in the article I'll show an
example of how you can do this
with your client side login on
a page that has the sign in
with Google button, and the log
in with Facebook button.
And we can go to the code now.
I'll give an overview of the
code here, but make sure to
look at the article after
the episode and
take a deeper look.
So what you can see here is
something that, in this case,
is called AuthStates.
And it's a central place to
manage authorization.
You can see on the screen the
code for when the user clicks
on log in with Facebook
button.
What you would normally do, is
initiate the login process
right in that block of code.
But when you're dealing with
multiple providers, it's
easier to offload your
authorization state to this
[INAUDIBLE] code that we've
written here and centralize
your choice of log in.
So for instance, in this case,
we want to let the user make a
choice between Google
and Facebook when
they're signing in.
But we also want to keep
the flow going quickly.
So the code here gives an
example of what you'd do if
the user is logged into
Google and Facebook.
In this case, we're going to go
ahead and log the user in
with Google.
Of course, you can customize
this to your preferences.
But what you can really see
here, and what the point is,
that none of the authorization
logic is mixed together.
And you don't have any
of these nasty
if-Google-else-Facebook
statements.
You centralize it, and then you
can go on to add three,
four identity providers and push
all the authentication to
this one central location.
Instead of creating messy code
that's hard to maintain.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
And so when you were creating
this central location, this
glue that holds everything
together, was there anything
about it that was particularly
difficult?
Or did you find that it started
to make sense once you
really had your mind
around it?
SAM STERN: So I think
you'll see--
once you implement a framework
like this--
that it all starts to make sense
when you think of your
providers as just ways a user
can connect to your website.
And don't try to let the
providers handle
each other's logic.
If you centralize it, you'll see
that you can take the flow
you had in your mind and really
implement it quickly in
your application.
And then you won't have to
maintain the same separate
pieces of code over an over.
You can do it all
in one place.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
Social identity providers have
a lot more than just
authentication, right?
And I guess my next question
is, how do some of these
features that are really similar
between Facebook and
Google+-- how did
you handle that?
SAM STERN: So in the feature
translation section of the
article, you'll see a breakdown
of if you're doing
something with Facebook, how you
can do the same thing or
similar thing on Google+
to keep it a consistent
experience for users.
One particular example is, if
you're used to publishing
information on the open graph
on Facebook, you should be
publishing app activities
to Google.
Which is Google's way of sharing
structured data from
your application about actions
the user has taken.
A user has listened to a
song, or rented a room.
Things like that that you might
have been pushing-- the
open graph you should push to
app activities on Google.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
And then how did you handle
the user experience across
multiple different
feature sets?
Did you have custom UIs?
Did you surface certain buttons
at certain times?
How did you really
handle that?
SAM STERN: So what the developer
really should focus
on is making your app shine.
But also highlighting the
identity provider that your
user chose.
So you want to present the
correct set of features at any
given time based on how the
user's signed in to your
application, without creating a
fragmented user experience.
For instance, if the user is on
a page that is sharable on
Facebook, you might want to have
Facebook's share button.
Whereas with Google, you
might want to have
an interactive post.
And this is something that you
can also discover in the
feature translation section,
about how to give a consistent
user experience without missing
what makes each network--
each social identity provider--
different.
Or why the user chose
to sign in with the
provider that they did.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
And on that note, what are some
things that are different
about Google+ that you think
Facebook developers might be
interested in?
SAM STERN: So there were three
main things that I was able to
add to my application after I
[INAUDIBLE] with Google that I
couldn't get before.
The first thing was over the
air installs, which is
something really powerful--
that if you have a user sign in
on the web, you can offer
them the opportunity
to sign in--
to install your Android
application to their device at
the same time.
When a user signs in to your
service once, they're signed
in on all their devices.
And this is a way to create a
really great user experience,
and get users to where they
actually want to be going in
your application.
And the third one is interactive
posts, which at
first might seem like a
share that a lot of
other providers have.
Interactive posts allow you to
really call the user to an
action on your application.
And this also goes with deep
linking, where you can bring
the user directly to what they
want to do on your app or on
your website.
Rather than just sharing
content, which is more
powerful and allows the user
to act more quickly.
JOANNA SMITH: Fantastic.
So let's go back to this article
that you wrote, right?
It seems to be pretty long.
There's a lot in there.
What can developers expect to
learn from this article?
What resources are available
to them there?
SAM STERN: So like you said,
there's a lot of content in
this article.
And hopefully what a developer
can see is that is a very
customizable framework for
managing multiple providers in
your application.
There's a lot of code here that
will work for you, but it
doesn't have to be
set in stone.
You can expand what's in the
article to fit the needs of
your application.
And hopefully you can go
from zero to hero with
Google+ very quickly.
And start from having just
Facebook on your website, to
have a fully functioning Google+
integration by the end
of the article.
JOANNA SMITH: So before we go,
before we sign off, I want to
put you on the spot.
And I want to know your favorite
part about interning
with us here in Mountain View
was, as well as your least
favorite part.
SAM STERN: So favorite
part is easy.
I sit about five feet from a
Foosball table, and I got
pretty good at Foosball playing
with everybody.
And I'm going to cheat and
have two favorite parts.
I also really like the food,
which I think everybody who
comes to Mountain View says.
And my least favorite part,
coming from the East coast,
would be the tech bubble
of the Silicon Valley.
It's hard to go anywhere
within 50 miles without
hearing about the latest
app or website.
Which sometimes it can
be a little much.
JOANNA SMITH: That's a
very true statement.
Well, thank you so much for
joining us today, Sam.
We really appreciated you taking
the time to do this
episode before you go
back to school.
And once again, everyone
watching at home, if you'd
like to see the full scope of
what Sam did this summer, you
can go to developers.googl
e.com/+/web/facebook.
And of course, all of our
documentation is there as well.
And you can learn everything you
wanted to know about the
Google+ platform, or how to
get started if you're a
Facebook developer primarily.
And then of course, if you have
questions about this, ask
them to us.
We'll answer.
On Stack Overflow, if you use
the tag Google-+, we'll be
able to find it.
And then if you'd like to see
some code of how our samples
work, or how to sign in, or how
the button works, check
out our GitHub repository
at github.com/google+.
And then if you find a bug, or
if you have a feature request,
let us know in our
issue tracker.
And all of these resources are
available in our documentation
at developers.google.com/+.
So thank you for joining, and
I hope you all have a
wonderful week.